Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning. My name's Alan Rice.
I'm a pastor elder here for 21 years and our lead teaching Pastor
John, uh,
he has been on sabbatical for three months and we've had a number of
really, uh, great preachers fill in. I'm not one of them, uh,
but uh, I am the last one. The bottom of the barrel.
John will be back next week.
Now I'm gonna start our sermon off this morning with a story of one of my
adventures for some reason known only to God.
He seems to throw some pretty wild adventures my way from time to time
adventures I shouldn't experience as an English professor now retired
and as a pastor elder, it was Monday,
June 9th, 2008. I was nearly 50 years old at the time.
The location was AK Garri Island on the barren coast of Northern Ireland.
My lovely wife Deedee and I were on vacation doing the self tour
of all the countries of Great Britain. Now,
AK Garri Island is a natural tower of stone surrounded on all sides by
massive cliffs that go down to the jagged rocks by the sea.
We stood on the highest point of the island and looked out at a spectacular view
about 220 foot height over the broad and open ocean.
Now if you look at the picture up here, these cliffs look nice,
but to see the grand scale,
if you go to the far left to the top of the cliff and the grass,
you can see some lines of white going along a line.
Those are human beings.
That's how massive these cliffs are.
We took a deep breath and we soaked it all in.
Deedee sat down on a tuft of grass to meditate and pray.
I walked forward to get a better view of the sea. Don't go near the cliff.
Deedee warned I choke to myself because I wasn't that stupid.
So when I came to the cliff's edge,
I might be inclined to walk up to the very edge like this and look over,
but I was smarter than that because that little section could fall away.
So instead I did a wide stance like this with my,
my foot on my back or my weight on my back foot.
And I approached the cliff like this and before I could even look over the
whole large section fell away.
Now I had a lot of thoughts go through my head at that second as you can guess,
but one thought that I had was, come on,
I was doing the whole spreading leg thing. I mean,
what are the odds of that whole section falling away?
And my second thought was completely calm, crystal clear. It's this,
I'm gonna die. And I wasn't mournful about it or panicking,
it was just a scientific fact. Okay, fair enough.
But my third thought was, I'm really fascinated how I'm gonna die.
I mean, am I gonna sail 20 stories,
watching my the rocks come up and see them as I hit?
Am I gonna pass out from horror? Am I gonna hit my head on the cliff?
I was really interested in what was gonna come next.
So when I fell, my feet came together and my head went up.
So I didn't get to see what happened next,
but I felt a really hard bump on where I sit down on the right,
I guess as I came down I hit a jagged rock. I didn't hang up,
but it might have slowed me down. The next thing, boom,
both of my feet hit solid rock
and it was such a strong force downward from my fall that I
stumbled forward.
And now I am with my toes over the edge of the cliff looking 20
stories down and I'm ah, ah, and then I back up to the cliff.
I look up,
I have fallen 15 feet down a shear cliff and I'm only on a ledge
about five foot wide and about four foot between me and death.
I am stranded on a shear cliff all alone without help or hope
when I preach,
I like to state my thesis right up front so everyone can follow what I'm trying
to say today.
My thesis is really a kind of a theme and it's just four words long and it's the
top of the sermon notes.
It is this far away from home
standing on that little cliff overlooking a 20 story drop.
I was far away from home.
I was far away from home from the red dirt plains of Oklahoma and I felt
equally as far away from home from my lovely wife who was only physically about
a hundred yards away, far away from home.
Today we're reading from Psalm 61,
I will read the whole psalm aloud from the English standard version and then
we'll go back and analyze it bit by bit
to the choir master with string instruments of David.
Hear my cry. Oh God, listen to my prayer.
From the end of the earth I call to you. When my heart is faint,
lead me to the rock that is higher than I for you have been
my refuge, a strong tower against the enemy.
Let me dwell in your tent forever.
Let me take refuge a under the shelter of your wings,
Sayah for you, oh God have heard my vows,
you have given me the heritage of those who fear your name.
Prolong the life of the king. May his years endure to all generations.
May he be in enthroned forever before God appoint
steadfast love and faithfulness to watch over him.
So will I ever sing praises to your name as I perform
my vows? Day after day
the Psalm starts out with David, uh, telling us the setting.
David is far away from home in verse one.
In the first part of verse two, David states hear my cry. Oh God,
listen to my prayer from the end of the earth,
I call to you when my heart is faint.
Why is David so distraught? Why is his heart so faint?
Because he is far away from home,
which is to say far away from God.
In the Old Testament, God is everywhere just as he is now omnipresent.
But in those days,
God chose especially to inhabit the Ark of the Covenant which was housed
in Jerusalem. So he uh, David was in Jerusalem,
that was his capital. So when he was there,
he was always close to the Ark of the Covenant and therefore he felt he was
close to God. But in this psalm,
David is obviously not near Jerusalem and therefore he is not close to
God. He is as he states at the ends of the earth.
Why might that be?
Most biblical commentators agree that it is probably because David is in the
part of his life when he had to flee Jerusalem
in about 10 30 BC when David was roughly 61 years old,
his son Absalom revolted against him, seized the throne,
and forced David to flee for his life in into the wild wilderness.
Now I've had the honor of visiting the Baron wilderness of Israel and it really
does feel like the end of the earth,
especially when compared to the city of Jerusalem,
cut off from his court, cut off from his homeland and cut off from his God.
David felt that he was at the end of the earth.
So sermon point number one, David is far away from home.
David's epic journey homeward in this psalm is universal in its themes.
Some of the world's most beloved heroes had to leave their home and found
themselves far away from home.
Odysseus and Homer's Odyssey,
Dorothy and the Wizard of Oz and Frodo and Lord of the Rings all were forced
away from their homes and went on long journeys to try to get
back.
This quest of the hero trying to find his or her way home is so mythic,
so resonant in our culture that without quite recognizing it,
we play games that reflect this journey of the hero,
the board game of life, of Candy Land, of Wahoo,
and especially of the board game. Parici, which I bought for this moment,
reflects this journey.
So in Parici you start all the way at the edge of the
board at the end of the world and you have to go on this
circuitous journey forever and your goal is to get to the center,
to Jerusalem, let's say, which says in big letters home.
And yet David's journey is different than that of the other heroes.
David doesn't use Odysseus's, brilliant intellectual,
cunning or Dorothy's ability to form a family or frodo's inner goodness
to get him through his journey,
but rather David overcomes all of his obstacles in his
path by his absolute dependence upon
God.
Notice that David focuses on his own inadequacy in this journey.
He admits in verse two that his heart is faint.
Furthermore, he calls upon God and God alone. When he writes,
hear my cry, oh God,
listen to my prayer from the end of the earth I call to you when
my heart is faint,
David cries out to God in desperation, he prays to God,
he he calls out to God because his heart is faint and he knows that he
cannot rely upon himself to get home.
When David was at his best,
he was like Jesus desperately dependent
upon God.
One of the very few bright spots I have in my personal Christian walk is
that I'm addicted to intimacy with God.
The New Testament calls intimacy with God,
walking in the Holy Spirit or walking in the light,
and that is my burning yearning desire every day As a Christian.
Deedee and I love an old Kerry Grant movie where he and his wife talk about the
deep intimacy between the two of them as being like an ongoing music,
a harmony in their hearts.
I long for that music between God and myself every day that walking in
the Holy, holy Spirit,
I get there like many Christians by practicing what are called the spiritual
disciplines.
For me that means a hunger for Bible study and a thirst for
meditation upon God and his word.
The sad news is I am not the most disciplined when it comes to long intense
prayer like I should be. But when I'm walking in the Holy Spirit,
at least I whisper conversational prayers with God all day
long. But something happens to me when I get sick.
I don't know why I go into robot mode and just
try to survive the brownish bra,
gray haze of life until I can feel better.
My Bible study time is mundane,
my meditation time is diminished and my whispered
conversations with God completely evaporate.
I keep thinking Tamara feel better and I can get back to real life.
But when I have a protracted illness,
I realize over time that I have not been walking in the Holy Spirit and I'm not
in harmony with God.
For the last year and a half I've been struggling with one protracted illness
after another from c o d to bronchitis, to pneumonia,
maybe twice because of my illness,
I have often failed to seek harmony with God and I feel that I
am sometimes spiritually anemic
like David.
I am sometimes far away from home,
but I think I'm not alone in this,
all of humanity feels the impact of being far away from home
with God.
The Bible tells us in the book of Genesis that when God created human beings,
Adam and Eve, they were in perfect harmony with God.
God could literally walk with Adam in the cool of the day,
but those first humans, Adam and Eve, chose to sin.
That is they chose to disobey God,
to revolt against him in their hearts and to obey their own impulses as
if they are their own gods.
Adam and Eve sin has influenced all human beings so that we all choose
to sin against God. Therefore,
we are cut off from harmony with God because God is so
absolutely pure and holy.
He cannot be in harmony with those people like all of us who
are corrupted by sin. However,
the writer of Ecclesiastes and Ecclesiastes three 11 states
that God has placed eternity in our human hearts.
Therefore, we all yearn for that harmony with God that is missing
in our lives.
Every civilization in the world seems to know this is true.
They know there's a God, they yearn for him,
and yet they also know we are all separated from him.
Every civilization tries to reach their arms up to God,
to close that gap between God and humanity.
People have tried to reach up to God by, by prayers,
by rituals, by fasting, by self denial,
by good works, by animal sacrifices to idols,
by ceremonious cutting themselves,
even by sacrificing their children on the fire of pagan altars.
But nothing seems to close that infinite gap between humanity and God.
Nothing can bring us the intimacy with him that our hearts
crave. Sermon note number two,
we were all,
all of us far away from home.
Let's finish reading the rest of verse two. From the end of the earth,
I call to you, when my heart is faint,
lead me to the rock that is higher than I.
What is this rock At the literal level,
it's just a natural tower of cliffs, of of rock with cliffs on all sides.
The perfect place for a British isles to put a castle or an Israel.
Masada is such a place.
So what David is saying that he wants to God to take him to the top of a tower
of rock so David will be safe and secure from all of his enemies.
Why does David need God to take him to such a place?
Because if David could climb up there,
then so could his enemies and it wouldn't be safe and secure. After all,
David is yearning for a safety for a security that only God
can provide. As I was standing on that little legend,
Northern Ireland overlooking a terrifying 200 foot
plunge to death,
I could well have sympathized with David's desire for God to take him
to that rock that was higher than himself
at the literal level. The rock in verse two is a just a high tower of rock,
but at the figurative or the metaphorical level,
the rock is God and God alone
As he was in verse one,
David is being totally dependent upon God here
He yearns for God to take him to that higher rock,
which is the only place of real safety and security.
Many of us in this room might try to find safety and security and money
that is until it's gone.
We might try to find safety and security in our job, in our status,
in our families, in our health until they're gone.
Such things only give us the illusion of safety because they are here with us on
this lowly ground.
Only God can lead us to the rock to himself that is higher
than ourselves.
Has God ever been a rock for you in your life?
Only God can lead us to the point of living for something higher,
something grander than our own lives.
Sermon note number three,
only in the rock of God can we find safety and
security.
How can we know for sure that the rock in verse two is metaphorically really
God? Because David makes it crystal clear in verse three,
for you have been my refuge, a strong tower against the enemy.
So David states outright here that God has been David's rock, his refuge,
his strong tower in times past,
and David is pleading with God to be so once again in this dark
hour And then things get even sweeter and deeper.
In verse four, when David writes,
let me dwell in your tent forever.
Notice that David isn't just asking for mere safety and security here.
He's asking for a real relationship with God
according to the Hebrew scholars of the new English translation,
the English phrase,
let me dwell in your tent in the Hebrew of Psalm 61 really
means,
let me live as a resident foreigner in your tent as
a resident foreigner.
David acknowledges here that he's not worthy of citizenship in God's kingdom.
He is far away from home.
He is a human being who is sinful and fallen, but even as a foreigner,
he wants God to grant him the legal right to dwell as a
resident in the tense of God so he can be nearer to God
as people who sin.
We cannot expect or demand that God embrace us in our fallen state,
but like David,
we can cry out to God that he would somehow make us able to be
in his presence.
Notice that David isn't just talking anymore about shelter from his
enemies on this earth.
He has transcended focusing upon getting back to Jerusalem to the physical
arch, the covenant and now is asking instead for God to let him come
to his real home
in God's presence for eternity.
Notice how David calls after God to let him dwell as a resident for and God's
tent, but notice the following word forever.
So sermon note number four,
God can give us a new home with him.
Then comes an even sweeter,
an even deeper moment as we read the rest of verse four.
Let me take refuge under the shelter of your wings.
David is metaphorically describing God as a mother bird gathering little birds
under her wing in a time of danger.
Jesus uses this same metaphor of himself and elaborates upon it a little in
Matthew 2337 O, Jerusalem, Jerusalem,
the city that kills the prophets and stones, those who are sent to it.
How often I would gather have gathered your children together as a hen gathers
her brood under her wings and you were not willing.
The mother hen here is providing safety and security for her chicks in a time of
danger,
but David covered that concept and the rock that is higher than eye passage.
So I think this mother hen metaphor is emphasizing two additional things
to safety and security.
The first thing I noticed here is intimacy.
In the passage we'd read earlier,
David pleased to be a resident foreigner in one of God's tens.
But here the relationship is much more intimate.
Here David is calling out to God to take him under his wings.
Snuggling up under God's wings is much more intimate than merely being in one of
God's tents, and in this metaphor,
David isn't some resident foreigner,
but rather he is one of God's own little chicks.
This metaphor makes David part of God's own family.
That is new, that is powerful.
The second thing I noticed here is not just safety and intimacy but also
sacrifice.
The mother hen gathers her chicks under her wing so that the predator,
like the fox, for example, will attack her and not her children.
She is literally laying her life down for her chicks
and that ladies and gentlemen is what Jesus Christ did
for all of us.
He was born as the only person in history who was a hundred percent God
and a hundred percent man.
He lived the perfectly sinless life that none of us could ever do,
and he sacrificed himself upon a cross to take all of our sins
upon him as we as He died.
If we become Christians,
that is if we accept Jesus as our savior to save us from our sins,
past, present, and future,
and as our Lord so that he is the person in charge of all the rest of our lives.
Jesus' sacrifice upon the cross takes away all of our sins
and restores that intimacy,
that harmony with God that we have always longed for.
We literally are adopted and become part of God's family
like little chicks under a mother's wing.
Sermon note number five,
sacrifice gives us our new home when we are
part of God's family.
We are no longer far away from home.
We are home. We are home at last.
David intuitively here knows this because for the rest of Psalm 61,
after the sayah, after the break,
he is no longer crying out and pleading to God as if he is far away
from home.
But rather he speaks with the deep assurance of someone who knows
he's in full harmony with God. Verse five, for you,
oh God have heard my vows,
you have given me the heritage of those who fear your name.
The heritage David speaks of here is that heritage of intimacy,
of harmony with God and ultimately of living forever with
him as a part of God's family.
The final verses of the Psalm shift to David praying for blessings upon
the king.
Verse six and following,
Prolong the life of the king. May his years endure to all generations.
May he be enthroned forever before God appoint
steadfast love and faithfulness to watch over him.
So while I ever sing praises to your name, as I perform my vows day after day,
who is this king that David is praying for? Is it himself?
If so,
why does he suddenly refer to himself in the distant third person as he and as
the king when the previous passages or in the first passionate direct first
person of I and me? Most biblical commentators see two kings here,
both at the same time.
The first king is indeed David himself.
After his traumatic ordeal with his son and Absalom's revolt,
David is asking for God to give him long life and to bless and restore his
kingdom with love and with faithfulness.
David seems to have faith here that God will restore and bless him and therefore
David dedicates himself to honor God with his vows and to continually
sing praises to him.
As is so often the case with the psalm, the psalmist starts out,
the Psalm gripped with panic,
looking at the dire circumstances of this chaotic world,
but ends the Psalm in peace and harmony as he is now focusing
upward upon God.
So far so great and yet there is
something in the wording of these last three verses that seem to transcend am
mere call for blessings upon David the king.
It's as if David has achieved such harmony with God that the end of this psalm,
he has slipped into the future prediction of prophecy
As many but biblical commentators believe David is speaking of himself,
but he is more profoundly speaking of a second king. Jesus,
the Messiah who is to come.
Verse six, prolong the life of the king.
May his years endure to all generations.
David's life cannot endure to all generations,
but Jesus the Son has always been and always will
be.
He is here with us now and he will be with us
for all generations no matter how wildly this world spins out of
control. Verse seven,
may he be enthroned forever before God appoint
steadfast love and faithfulness to watch over him.
40 days after Jesus rose from the dead,
he ascended and into heaven before the eyes of his disciples,
and he now sits at the right hand of the Father.
Literally as this verse states enthroned forever before
God.
Amen.
Steadfast love and faithfulness. Don't just watch over Jesus,
but rather Jesus's steadfast love and faithfulness watches
over us. Verse eight,
so will I ever sing praises to your name as I perform my vows
day after day,
even as David vows to serve God his Lord.
So we too live our lives every day in service to our savior
and our forever Lord, always singing praises to his name.
Let us remember that in just a few minutes as we sing praise to our God,
I began this sermon with a literal cliffhanger.
What happened to me on that tiny ledge with the horrifying drop below,
I was in such a state of adrenaline shock that without really thinking it
through,
I immediately turned and began trying to scale that 15 foot
shear cliff.
I was hoping that deedee hadn't seen me fall and that I could make it back up
the cliff without her knowing that I fell.
Don't go near the cliff
as I was crawling my way up the side,
I vaguely remember handholds and footholds slipping beneath my weight and rocks
and pebbles falling down the cliff below.
But I was obsessed with getting to Deedee,
Looking back at it all. Now,
if someone had airlifted me to that little ledge and left me there,
I never in a million years would try to climb that cliff.
The odds of falling to my death would seem overwhelming,
but I was in the adrenaline shock zone, so I kept climbing.
I got safely to the top of the cliff and crawled 20 feet or so onto the
ground, beyond rolled over, laid on my back for perhaps a minute,
just trying to understand what just happened here.
Then I turned and crawled over to the cliff's edge again like an idiot it.
But this time I slithered forward on my stomach
and I stared over the edge of more than 20 stories below to those jagged rocks,
and I looked up the cliff face as far as I could see to the left.
I looked up the cliff face as far as I could see to the right,
and the only ledge in all the cliff face was that little four foot ledge
directly below me.
I've had many near-death experiences in my life.
Here are just a few examples. I've been attacked by a mad bull.
Years later I was attacked by a homicidal cow.
I've had a heart pounding close encounter with a mountain lion in the wilderness
with my leg bleeding to lure them on.
I've been trailed by a pack of hungry wolves in the Rocky Mountains at midnight
and once coming back from a mission trip to Wales,
our United Airlines commercial jet lost an engine over the
Atlantic Ocean.
Stephanie Miller was on that flight with me.
I don't remember who else was there.
I've since read online that only one in a million flights lose an engine.
Therefore, for what happened to you,
you could reasonably say that's some pretty bad luck.
But of all the adventures I've experienced,
I would rank my fall off the cliff in Northern Ireland as the one most
overwhelmingly likely to kill me.
The second I went over that edge,
I would say my odds were absolutely zero.
Why am I alive? Why did God let me live?
I don't know.
Did he have an angel pushing me up the cliff from behind as the hand holes gave
way? I don't know. Maybe
I won't say that I'm haunted by this, but when I think about that cliff,
I often look up my life to see if there's anything in it that might be the
reason for God to keep me from dying that day and all those other days of my
crazy adventures. And I have to tell you honestly, church,
I don't see it. I haven't found the cure for cancer.
I haven't run into a burning building to save a school full of children.
Even when I add up all the component parts of my life, my role in my family,
my work, our church, our missions to wells,
it just doesn't amount enough to help me understand.
I don't see enough merit in all that I am and all that I've done to warrant
surviving such ridiculous odds no matter how hard I
added up. But I think that's the point.
There's nothing that I've done that might be enough for God to let me live that
day,
and that is the definition of grace.
There's nothing in my life good enough for God to save me in Northern Ireland,
and there's nothing good enough in our lives for God to save us from our sins
and to adopt us into his family.
It is just grace.
It is just Jesus being Jesus.
It is just Jesus being the rock.
Sermon note number six,
grace and grace alone through faith brings us home.
What are the cliff ledges you are stranded upon in your life?
It could be a struggle with a family member or a friend.
It could be bad news about your job or your health,
or it could be anxiety, depression, or addiction.
Maybe you just feel far away from God.
Know that you are not alone on that ledge.
God sees you. God's got you.
Jesus is the rock that is higher than us.
Maybe you can remember how you ran under his wings in times past.
He is here now just like he was then,
and he wants to be in sweet harmony with you and me.
I'll be here in the front at the end of our service, so will other elders,
staff members, counselors, we'd love to talk with you and pray with you.